costars of Will and Grace taking on
Trump supporters Debra Messing and
edrick eric mccormack the latest to face
fierce backlash after close of the names
of those in Hollywood who will be
attending an upcoming Trump fundraiser
to be outed just the latest example from
some on the Left trying to intimidate
the president's backers but the two
actors being criticized even by their
fellow celebrities the view co-host
Whoopi Goldberg had some strong words
his will be you are the idea of who you
don't want to work with is your personal
business do not encourage people to
print out lists because the next list
that comes out your name will be on and
then people will be coming after you in
this country people can vote for who
they want to that is one of the great
rights of this country you don't have to
like it
[Applause]
we don't go after people because we
don't like who they voted for we don't
go after them that way we can talk about
issues and stuff but we don't print out
lists Bravo Whoopi so I've loved her for
decades yes Katie this reminds me of the
the Castro brother Joaquin the
congressman brother of who Leon the
presidential candidate outing all of the
Trump supporters in San Antonio is this
the new tactic well they weren't just
Trump supporters the ironic thing about
them outing Trump supporters in El Paso
is that a lot of the people on the list
were actually Castro supporters as well
who had given donations to him you know
they donated Republicans and Democrats
based on their right to do so and yet it
backfired so when Debra Messing calls
for the list of tron supporters to be
released she's not doing it for the good
of the country for some good cause she's
doing it so that these people in
Hollywood can't work again there's an
underground movement in Hollywood it's
been there for 30 years about
conservatives who work in Hollywood who
stay quiet do their jobs they can't come
out publicly and talk about politics
even though you see it at award shows
and the left is allowed to talk about it
whenever they want and shove it down
your throat but when it comes to having
a different point of view Hollywood
actresses like Debra Messing and people
who have a lot more credibility and
power than she does in Hollywood think
that you should believe in leftism that
you have a monolithic thought process
and if you
we're going to harass you we're going to
print your phone number in your address
her family will be harassed and you will
never work a day again that's why she's
doing it and it's disgraceful so Whoopi
Goldberg stood up for them good on her
but releasing lists of names usually
goes one way it's a left calling for it
to be released on the right and you
never know these people may support both
parties and yet you still want to out
them as Trump supporters and punish them
for their their thoughts the thought
police essentially you know reminds me
this is the exact opposite of the
McCarthy era yeah in those days there
was the right-wing was persecuting the
left-wing now it's the other way around
yes still stinks how is certainly
ignorant you have to be to be Hollywood
actress and call for someone to be
blacklisted really did she not know the
history of her own country or industry
you know the other thing is she put out
a tweet and says we need to come
together let's talk let's really talk
and she put out a phone number so I'm
gonna call the phone number and I'm just
gonna try to talk to her and see what
she says she will the number right now
yeah that's call right now it writes
people put it on the speaker because you
can't say you want to bring people
together and then you want a blacklist
people because that just hurts their
families that hurts the entire industry
because you're gonna deprive right
Hollywood and all the audience's of
[Music]
[Music]
here's the thing thing is she's
definitely talented and Will and Grace
was a good show I don't think the remake
is having the same success but we were
just going over some rough list of
celebrities that would be going to the
Donald Trump event obviously people with
money or else they wouldn't go to
Beverly Hills but Kelsey Grammer right
yeah Clint Eastwood Dean Cain Jon Voight
and the creator of the creator of The
Apprentice Mark Burnett
may you be going so bottom line is this
is the one thing rather I'll take a page
from your book I
think take Donald Trump in this campaign
should be going to areas that disagree
with them and and having this debate
when John McCain did great and this is
the beginning this is saying don't
bother it's not worth it and I want him
to go to Beverly Hills I wanted to go to
Chicago I want to go to those places not
just places that love them and make
challenge people to challenge him well
he always jokes about if you had to
campaign in California right with the
electoral college she would have any
movement I hear it that Republicans if
you're a Republican you're a racist Dana
I mean I hear that that's how far it has
gotten in in this era in which we
freshing to have somebody like Whoopi
Goldberg who constantly consistently
points that out as being faulty and she
she speaks from the what she's
passionate about but from what she
speaks but she also speaks from position
of somebody who has been targeted in the
past by others so I think that she's
she's a good counter but the thing about
somebody like Debra Messing is that they
learn nothing every time they do
something like this it is like when
pac-man goes around and he eats like one
of the little fruits it strengthens
President Trump
it gives him so if they were just be
quiet it was a - and now we don't play
pac-man anymore and I'm gonna talk about
that later in the break but I just want
one thing out one thing I like quality
per the brain right oh one thing I would
love to bring up Stephen Ross to paying
the price he owns Hudson Yards he's that
rich guy wants the Dolphins they're
gonna move their fashion show out
because he had the audacity just have a
fundraiser in the Hamptons which some
people I know went to I can't imagine
who he's speaking about right so I just
think people just gotta stop the broad
boycotts the protests and the lists can
we just have an election